طيب على المستوى السياسي يعني في الاوساط
السياسيه والاعلاميه كيف يتم التعاطي مع
الاحداث في موسكو او في روسيا
نعم هناك حذر شديد من قبل اداره الرئيس جو
بايدن في التعامل مع هذه التطورات وتنظر
اليها
بحد كبير من الخطوره كون روسيا بلد نووي
هذه الفوضى في حال استمرت يمكن ان توقع من
الترسانه النوويه او جزء من الترسانه
النوويه في ايضا خطره في نهايه المطاف
مجموعه مرتزقه
لا
تتحكم
بتصرفاتها منطق الدوله
الاعراف التي جرى التعامل بها في المسائل
النوويه خصوصا بين الدول المعنيه هذا من
ناحيه من ناحيه ثانيه هناك وجهه نظر
امريكيه تقول ان
هذه التطورات اظهرت الى حد كبير ضعف
الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين على رغم الادعاءات الطويله
بانه يمسك بشكل حازم بالوضع في في روسيا
كل هذه المسائل يجري النظر فيها داخل
الولايات المتحده باعتبارها تطورات خطيره
وطبعا بطبيعه الحال الولايات المتحده
اعلنت على ارفع المستويات انها ستواصل دعم
اوكرانيا في تصديها للغزو الروسي بصرف
النظر عن هذه التطورات وهي تنسق مع كافه
الحلفاء من اجل مواصله هذا الدعم من اجل
تمكيني اوكرانيا من الدفاع عن نفسها وايضا
من تحرير الاراضي التي احتلتها القوات
الروسيه طوال الاشهر 16 الماضيه طيب ان
طلاق المدرسه
شان داخلي ولكن كيف يمكن استغلال هذه
اللحظات يعني يعني هناك تصريحات لسلط
يتحدث عن هشاشه النظام الروسي هل على
الاستراتيجي تحاول ادار امريكيه ربما
اغتنام هذه الفرصه
يعني هناك اكثر من مساله في هذا السؤال
المهم للغايه اولا وجهه النظر الغربيه
تؤكد بصوره عامه ان هناك ضعف في قياده
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
للبلاد علما انه موجود في السلطه منذ اكثر
من عشرين عاما وهذا يثير الكثير من
التساؤلات حول ما يمكن ان يحصل خلال
الايام والاسابيع والاشهر وربما السنوات
المقبله في ظل مخاوف جديه من ان
ما يحصل يمكن ان يؤدي الى اضطرابات خطيره
داخل روسيا من راينا خلال نهايه الاسبوع
الماضي كيف
تمكنت قوات فاجنر من المرتزقه من الزحف
الى مسافه قريبه للغايه
من العاصمه الروسيه وهذا طبعا يثير الكثير
من القلق وكان يمكن ان يؤدي الى تداعيات
خطيره على صعيد الوضع في روسيا وعلى صعيد
كل المنطقه والعالم لان دوله مثل روسيا
الدوله رئيسيه ثانيا هناك
اعتقاد داخل اداره الرئيس جو بايدن بانه
ينبغي
لتمكين اوكرانيا من
استغلال نقاط الضعف الضروريه التي ظهرت
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه من اجل
مساعده اوكرانيا على التخلص من اعباء
الحرب التي قادتها روسيا هذا الغزو وتحرير
اراضيها وفي الوقت ذاته هناك حسابات لكل
الاحتمالات التي يمكن ان تحصل
وهذا كله لا ينفي حقيقه ان الولايات
المتحده والدول الغربيه تنعى بنفسها عن كل
التطورات التي حصلت الولايات المتحده تقول
عبر مسؤوليها انها لم تتدخل في هذه
التطورات الداخليه ولكن هذه التطورات تعكس
مدى تصدعات الموجوده داخل
القياده السياسيه في روسيا بدءا من راس
الهرم الرئيس بلادي ميركب شكرا جزيلا لك